how did you get here
[ __ ] I took a bus nobody's supposed to
be here we'll be jacking the fool I
tried them nothing for the last
Oh what is going on YouTube you miss me
yeah just a little break but look at the
Hammers going up nice and long women you
don't want to touch me at all do you
I like being alone it feels good now
racially if you guys have heard that has
been a stir up because Clippers owner
Donald sterling apparently is a racist
now how do we find out about this us
apparently there was a recording between
him and his mistress where he let out a
few races tidbits mmm now in this
conversation he stated that he did not
like her blasting out all social media
how she hung out with blacks or
specifically Magic Johnson all time but
you already know I'm ready to talk about
this so you already know what it is LGI
baby let's get it out why the [ __ ] is
everyone so surprised Oh didn't think
I'll go say that did you
hmm now to know what surprised this man
has faced multiple lawsuits about his
racism and how he conducts his business
so my big question to you now is what's
the big deal now he stated that he did
not want Latino to vent for him because
well obviously according to him all they
do is smoke and loiter around his
buildings and black people because well
they stink and they attract vermin and
to that I say [ __ ] who you got was
stinky with Joe H&S self looking like a
deflated marshmallow and you know what
else this [ __ ] said he said he
likes Korean tenants in k-town because
we just take his shitty living
situations and never complain about
really what the [ __ ] are you talking
about do you realize that Koreans are
the most angriest Asians on earth do you
even know how the Korean War was started
huh it was one Korean leader he was so
[ __ ] angry that he got in a fight
with his own reflection listen Donald
sterling is like one burning cross away
from a Ku Klux barbecue when I saw a
picture of him do you think I was
shocked I don't give a [ __ ] what you say
he has to be at least a hundred and
twenty years old he's racist are you
surprised
of course he is look at him even like
you own a couple of slaves at a certain
point how much you want to bet if you
walked behind him and you whisper some
slave lingo he turn around so fast
excuse me Mansell yes [ __ ] no that's
not my name what I don't know
oh yeah racist [ __ ] now let's talk
about his a rational thought process
here for a second how do you hate people
of color when you own a basketball team
you don't want black people at your
games but you want a 90% of your team
missing the only black dude all the
separates that might get it passed with
Donald sterling is Blake Griffin because
he says he's half black I still know
what the [ __ ] he is mmm why Blake
Griffin look like he dyed his hair and
does white face you ever notice how
racist people look at Blake Griffin they
look at him like he's a Picasso and [ __ ]
hey get the [ __ ] out of here you [ __ ]
wait get what what are you is he why I
don't touch this I don't know because
you hold his fuzz but did you realize
that your mistress is half black half
latina according to your remarks you
should probably dump it real soon
because you know she gonna be smoking
and loading a buddy a house stinking up
the place and Regan Berman in right you
dumb [ __ ] I hate you which brings me up
to the fact that there's good half of
you people out there that are praising
her for what she did you recorded his
racist ass good job good job that
despite the fact that you already knew
how he was as a human being how much he
hates and has belittle your ethnicity
and your culture that you would still be
with him and eat from the palm of his
hand cuz we all know you with him to be
a great person right wrong it must be
because of his good looks right wrong it
must be because he's a billionaire all
the birds a [ __ ] death right they may
think cuz we all know is the dick ain't
good I bet the money feel better now
what do you agree with his beliefs are
not and I'm not condoning his racism
because I hate that part about him but
you can tell it the conversation that
she was constantly egging him on to drag
out his racist remarks lady you are not
a hero you took a private conversation
and you fed the media exactly what they
wanted in the most sleaziest way
possible good job acting like you robbed
another [ __ ] more like robbing the gray
[ __ ] ass at it you know it's funny
because despite the fact that the
Clippers organization already knew this
stuff about it it took a leak of a
private conversation for them to
actually do something so let me ask you
this why now now why would an
organization who already knew about his
past behaviors and how he is a human
being just suddenly decide to make a
scene about this you know it's kind of
funny how powerful money is is
and how can change public perception so
let me ask you something else if this
conversation was not like despite
everything they knew about Donald
sterling
well the Clippers organization or the
NBA in fact would have done anything
about this hmm
now I will know per se but I will tell
you this he has been a part of the
Clippers organization for three decades
and then some
so I guess issues of social justice
really aren't that big of a deal unless
you sweep it under the rug you know it's
kind of sad isn't it how decency
definitively becomes a fine line when
there's money involved mmm think about
it
Oh what is going on YouTube have you
could tell my hair is long and I'm
sweating in this room because it was a
hundred degrees today spool this away
but yet last week I was not available I
was a little bit rundown and I was tired
a little bit sick because I had not been
sleeping because I've been working so
hard so if you guys want to know what I
got my gear is always at go-for-broke
apparel calm and yes this is the special
white label shirt that comes with a
different fabric and of course special
edgings in the clothes yes at that time
so remember to cut your gear while it's
on sale yes it's on sale right now
because I love you guys and of course
all the other design that you saw before
yeah
last week we ran out sorry you missed
out but guys thank you guys for being
patient for one more week I really
needed that break to rest up and of
course I will see you guys next Sunday
and of course on Wednesday for funny fat
fit I will see you all next time oh if
you guys have heard haha conversation
that was recorded and then we're making
them wanna know the man yeah
conversation if you have heard of heat
now I'm gonna remember my name in a mini
mini minimum [ __ ] this hair about his
races nanana minimum how he can touch
his he conducts he couldn't touch his
belly fat in 2003 he was accused of 90
I'll buy that money money number what
the [ __ ] are you talking about
oops mmm unprofessional hardest time
verbally abusing break now my buddy be
removing me in a different fabric with
special s with a special what the [ __ ]
is special for our spring line we
started off with this wonderful
wonderful white what the [ __ ] is go
Jesus here we go hey [ __ ] you looking at
huh yes I thought back it up
do you even know other Korea what we
started huh no hmm do I even know [ __ ]